-We've talked a lot on the show
about "Second Chance Theater,"
sketches that -- that,
like, killed at the table...
-Yes. Yes.
-...and then died
in front of the audience.
-Oh, right, right.
-You had the reverse happen.
-Yes.
-Which, if you --
which is very hard to do.
I don't quite understand how --
how did you get a sketch on
that didn't have to go
to the table?
-This was an incredible moment.
I-I'm pretty sure this happened.
I don't remember everything.
It was a very long time ago.
[ Light laughter ]
But "The Herlihy Boy."
-Yeah.
-Okay, so what happened was,
I was starting to --
like, people were starting
to like some of the stuff I did.
And Lorne --
I wasn't on the show that week.
And Lorne said to Jim Downey,
"Adam's light.
Ask him if he has anything."
And -- And so after the --
you know,
usually, you've got to read
in front of the whole cast
and -- and the whole crew.
And if they laugh and --
you get it on.
If they don't, you know,
and a lot of times,
my stuff didn't work.
But this, "The Herlihy Boy" --
somehow, I was asked to be on.
I wrote it, like, late on
a Wednesday night and did it.
And that was
the sneakiest thing ever.
-Yeah.
-And for those who don't
remember "The Herlihy Boy,"
definitely go on YouTube
and look it up.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
That's -- Yeah.
-I mean, in the end, you know,
you really -- it's really
a sketch about Farley.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
That was the --
-You're "The Herlihy Boy."
-Right. Right.
-But you definitely --
you handed the best stuff off,
yeah.
-I had the title role.
But I knew the man.
The man -- that -- that was
a big move, man, in my era.
If you wrote Farley into a skit,
you knew it was probably
gonna get on.
And it was probably gonna be
a great time.
-You guys, this was --
growing up,
I remember watching this sketch
and enjoying "The Gap Girls"
a great deal.
-Sure. Yeah. That was fun.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Was it as much --
-That was fun, yeah.
-Yeah, yeah.
-That was Spade.
Spade used to write those.
-Spade wrote those?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
We had --
We had a great time doing that.
I used to -- I don't know.
Me and Farley didn't look
as good as Spade.
Spade kind of fit that stuff
better than us.
-Yeah, Spade
does kind of look...
-Yeah.
-Yeah, Spade has a nice
little body on him, and...
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-...me and Farley
are a little bigger -- bigger.
We didn't make sense
in the outfits.
-And Spade kept it,
because I remember
when Spade came back
and hosted in my era, he --
I think he played Martha Stewart
right away.
-Oh, right, right, right.
-Yeah.
So he's managed
to maintain that, yeah.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The -- The thing about Spade
in "Gap Girls"
is he's just talking
with his voice.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-No -- Everyone else
would put on, like,
a little higher, weird things.
He's just like,
"Hey, what's up, everybody?"
[ Laughter ]
-When we get back, I want
to talk about the special.
But one of the things
I want to say is, you know,
and I think this is true
of your work over your career
and why people care about you
so much and your work
is it's really funny,
but it's also really sweet.
And you had -- you sort of chose
to -- to do a song about Farley
in the special.
-Yeah, yes. Yes.
-And it seemed like such a thing
that everybody wanted to hear.
Was it --
When you first started doing it,
obviously, when you were working
on your special...
-Yeah.
-...was it nice to know
that everybody still wants
to connect to Farley that way?
-Oh. Oh, yeah, man.
I sang -- I remember the first
couple of times I sang it.
And it was a nice electric
feeling in the audience.
And everybody loved Farley
so much.
And any time I said his name,
people would cheer.
It was great.